[Musique]
cet homme par la chasse au trésor dans
les voûtes de l'office national du film
je vais regarder le match grâce et d
autre de la respecter de là précis puis
d'essayer de donner un petit souffle de
vie ce qu'ils cherchent des morceaux de
notre histoire de 1967 à 1981 pour la
part du diable luc bourdon a passé en
revue 2000 titres pour en retenir
finalement 175 c'est comme prendre 350
bois de parole comme celle là puis
d'ouvrir les bois de pin up choisir des
morceaux et après sun fois qu'on a fait
tout notre collection de morceaux mais
il faut les recoller pour faire un
nouveau pas haut
[Musique]
cet exercice le bourdon l'avait déjà
fait en 2008 pour son film la mémoire
des anges qui portait sur le montréal
des années 50 et 60
le réalisateur va bien au delà du
collage de morceaux choisis
moi j'ai toutes les fêtes les bandes
sonores des images sauf que synchro
n'est pas question qu'une musique
accompagne millimages pour lequel a été
créé il faut casser ça on fait pas de la
citation on doit créer une nouvelle
histoire à partir de vieilles histoires
de par ses choix et le traitement qu'il
en fait le réalisateur se fait l'avocat
du diable tous les sujets qui sont
là-haut l'opt est oublié mais ça a fait
des chicanes de famille dans chaque
famille ça veut dire que le nationalisme
les cheveux longs à la mode qui change
pas c'est du boulot dessus donc la part
du diable s'est un peu tous ces sujets
la religion entre autres c'est tous ces
sujets qu'on croise qui étaient des pas
mal des prises de tête pour ce film ce
n'est pas que la collection française de
louey neuf mais aussi la collection
anglaise qui est mise à contribution
oui au forum dédié ici mélanie
boissonneault radio canada montréal
l'apprenti
jama
[Musique]